Unplug your toaster and put earmuffs on your webcam because we are at war with machines
Personally I've been terrified of them ever since I saw that documentary wall-e
Damn those robots for making me cry
These tin cans are coming for our cars
They're coming for our sex lives
and they've been coming for our jobs for years ever since the first water wheel replaced Jeremiah the mill boy I
Tell you no one liked to crank it more than that guy
But thankfully one small business owner is raging Against the Machine
Trademark look this is Fabio. He was given a trial run with hopes
He would assist customers with their shopping needs, but after just a wee Fabio was fired
You would ask where the cheese is and he would say in the fridge, or where's the beer well
It's in the alcohol house, so he really wasn't helping customers
a
Supermarket greeter, who really wasn't helping customers damnit? They perfectly replicated human behavior that
Robot is exactly like the 17 year old stoner who doesn't want to work there
Look at it. It's already at a hoverboard, and it's programmed with attitude
Can you tell me where the milk is I don't know can I?
pitch perfect and
I'm claiming a victory because this bot lost its job
But they fired it in a completely wrong manner the mirror says when Fabio was told it was being let go and asked are
You angry?
Come on. It's tricked you into firing it like a human. You could just unplug it and put it back in the box
Take it outside. Don't let to look at the river and talk about the rabbits then power off
Just don't tell the thing it's fired because this firing might be what finally turns these gear heads from rumbas to doom bus